[Music]
what are the different types of elves of
middle earth and why are some of them
bestowed with tremendous powers
is it because of their biology as
immortal beings or is it like
specific talents that only a selected
individuals
possess or is it all in the bloodline
well we will tell you all about them in
this video do watch till the end as we
will also tell you which ones
which type of elves appeared in the
movies
what are elves they are the first
children of iluvata or the god of
creation of the world of middle earth
they are immortal and the fairest of the
races and also the wisest they came to
be in 1050 of the years of the trees a
total of 144 of them awoken and called
themselves the quendi from this main
branch come two groups one group that
followed the valor called oromi and they
are called the eldar while the ones that
refuse to follow him westwards are
called the avary elves there are three
types of elves in the elder the vaniar
which were the first to awaken the
naldor which are the second ones and the
tellery elves which are the last to
awaken some of the every elves the ones
that didn't follow the westward journey
were most probably the ones that melkor
captured corrupted and transformed into
orcs
so on their journey westwards a group of
the celery elves stayed back in the
greenwoods and lothlorien forest and
became known as the sylvan elves
while another group of delary elves made
their way to belarian and settled there
and became known as the green elves or
the la cuendi there were also a group of
gallery elves that were slow on their
journey and only arrived in belarian
after aromi had taken the elder to
velinor they became known as the syndar
elves and made their home in doriath
mithrim and the shores of phallus
all these elves that were stuck in
middle-earth are known as the elves of
darkness or the dark elves
or more quendy not because they are dark
and evil but they have never seen the
light of valinor they include the cindar
the sylvan the la cuendi and the avery
elves
the group of elves that followed oromay
to valinor that reached the western
continent were later known collectively
as the high elves as they were called by
the numenoreans or also the elves of
light or the calicuendi these elves
include the vanir
all of the naldor and a few of the
gallery elves
aside from these there were also elves
which are of mixed
in descent mix of heritage
take the likes of elrond and elvis they
were not only elves but also had their
blood mixed with that of the maya and
the great men of the first age so how
are they all different well biologically
they were all the same they were all
tall in stature slim and agile they had
fair complexion and were amongst the
bravest and the wisest of all races
they were also all immortal so the only
differences that they had between each
other are the choices they made in life
and the place they resided and not to
mention if they had seen the light of
valinor or not
so who are some of the most powerful
elves from that universe from middle
earth
well from the second ones odenaldo we
have feyenoord
fingolfin finrod galadriel turgon gil
galat and keller brimbaugh just to name
a few their source of power isn't a
different anatomy or a different
biological function but their talents as
elves that have seen the light of
valinor and that has strengthened their
resolve their spirituality and most of
all their minds take for example finn
golfing who is just another naldor elf
he managed to have a lengthy duel
against morgoth and even wounded the
dark lord seven times before being
defeated
feyenoor who was able to withstand his
ground against several balrogs and even
galadriel who managed to banish sauron
to murder from dolgodur such this would
have never been possible for any
ordinary elf
or even the most powerful of men
so what are the powers that these elves
have
well all elves themselves have greater
spiritual powers than humans as well as
being immortal
and they can't die unless true physical
injury or the loss of the will to live
they possess many gifts that humans
would not have
high elves have the ability to see
creatures of shadow like the nazgul and
the raids
and they are also considerably more
powerful than any other elf kind because
of the light of valinor that is within
them some of them have the ability to
summon the very magic or light of
valinor at will as well as having
tremendous telekinetic and telephotic
abilities as in the case of galadriel
where she could speak to frodo and
gandalf through the mine as well as move
things disintegrating an orc and even
banish sauron with her light
due to their longevity they also have
had a lot more time to train in the ways
of war
one can see that an elf can jump
gracefully from three to three have
smooth swinging motions during sword
fights and even shoot arrows in perfect
unison with near perfect aim
but they still seem to look fragile and
die from single swings of the sword
anyway take for example a cinder elf
legolas he is said to have far greater
senses than most non-elven living beings
capable of seeing and hearing at far
greater scales than men could never
missing a shot and fight with near
supernatural agility and flexibility as
well as climb up anything like a monkey
tower tree or olefont
thus bloodline have anything to do with
it with powers and all well maybe yes
and no it depends on the genetic
expressions of the elven offsprings
legolas is still a young elf but
powerful in his battle form nonetheless
much like his father trandwill arwen has
foresight something that most else do
not
but her father elrond also has
galadriel was the daughter of fennarfin
who himself has both naldor and vanir
blood in him galadriel was also the
niece of feyenoor the most important elf
in the first age and like her
predecessors she possesses extremely
potent abilities even though she has
never been to valinor which further
proves the point that bloodlines are
also an important
factor in this world
so let's address one thing
which are the kind of elves that was
seen in the lord of the rings and the
hobbit trilogy of movies
uh well the first ones that were seen in
the fellowship of the ring were the
cindering elves traveling to the shows
leaving for valeno
the the ones seen later in rivendell
were also cinderella and elves except
for elrond who was half human and arwen
who is his daughter and they were of
mixed descent even from the elven sign
on arriving in lorien most of the elves
in that place were sylvan elves except
for keller brimball and galadriel who
were both off the naldor stock
the ones seen in the battle of helm's
deep were also sylvan elves from lorien
lothlorian and from the hobbit movies
they were all sylvan elves from
greenwood a merkwit except for galadriel
again who was naldor and eldran who was
mix and also trendwill and
legolas who were cinderen elves
so now we come to the rings of power
that show what are the elves that will
be seen in it
that is still up for speculation as the
series hasn't aired yet but as of the
trailer and the posters we can make
certain educated guesses as well as
state the ones we know for a fact
so we do know that gladwell is one of
the main characters and she is nullo
we also have a younger elrond and he is
of mixed descent we then have a new elf
called arandir and he is a sylvan elf
then we have another important elf
called gil galad who is of nolo stock as
well he is the high king
the one that was killed by sauron in the
beginning of the movie lord of the rings
aside from these we are definitely going
to see more of the cinders and the
sylvans mostly and maybe a few of the
naldo or lit wendy and maybe even the
avari
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam
[Music]
you